on sunday there was a flurry of
diplomatic activity from g7 nations the
day before vladimir putin is due to
preside over victory day celebrations
commemorating the soviet defeat of the
nazis in world war ii the u.s first lady
made a surprise visit to a ukrainian
village just across the border with
slovakia there she met refugees and
ukraine's first lady the first time
olena zelenska had been seen in public
since the russian invasion
first of all i would like to thank you
for a very courageous act because we
understand what it takes for the u.s
first lady to come here during a war
this war has been brutal
and
that
people of the united states stand with
the people of ukraine
northwest of the ukrainian capital the
canadian prime minister also with a
surprise visit to the kiev suburb of
erpin that had once been occupied by
russian troops
he raised the flag over the canadian
embassy in the capital to mark its
reopening justin trudeau later held
talks with the ukrainian president and
announced new military and economic aid
on this anniversary of victory day in
europe
standing strong
against putin's illegal war
and in defense of democracy human rights
and international law
is as important as it ever has been
at the u.s embassy compound in kiev a
fleet of diplomatic vehicles carrying
the us charges de fer and her team this
was the first time since just before the
russian invasion that the embassy had
opened but u.s officials are there to
commemorate ve day with ukrainian
officials this is not the formal
reopening of the embassy that some in
the u.s congress have been demanding i'm
thrilled to be able to return to kyiv as
i said earlier today victory in europe
day
to observe the triumph of good over evil
in the city i love
among people who embody the spirit
of this commemoration
following their virtual meeting with the
ukrainian president g7 leaders pledged
an oil embargo on russia and the us
announced new sanctions on what the
state department called russian elites
as well as on the provision of business
services to russian companies on three
more russian tv stations and on
providing industrial equipment to russia
the g7 issued a statement designed to
poke at russian pride in defeating nazi
germany vladimir putin's actions it said
bring shame on russia and its people's
sacrifices in world war ii shia britancy
al jazeera washington